well extremely worried about these
strikes taking place uh my my husband
actually is an a e consultant so I know
he's working uh extra shifts as all of
his colleagues are to try and deal with
the issues but obviously when Junior
doctors are going on strike that's a
huge amount of capacity out of the
system and it's for several days so
really the government does now need to
properly engage in these talks which it
doesn't seem to have done so far and
find an urgent resolution to this
situation as it seems to have done for
for other health workers it needs to do
the same now for Virginia Doctors and
others so that we can uh we can get that
the National Health Service back to some
kind of of usual business
well you're putting the blame on the
government but what about the BMA
they're asking for a pay rise of up to
35 do they need to come up with a more
realistic proposal
well look these things are always a
matter of of negotiation aren't they but
uh my reading of the situation is is
that the government actually hasn't sat
around the table for any real meaningful
talks with the junior doctors and so
they haven't been able to establish
whether there is uh somewhere that they
could they could meet in the middle um
the government said the same thing
didn't they about the nurses demands for
for pay but they found a resolution with
the nurses uh unions and those strikes
have now uh have now stopped happening
so I think the lesson of of recent weeks
where resolution has been found is very
clearly that you can find a resolution
if you engage in proper uh talks but
just talking through the media really
about uh how these demands are
unrealistic and so on is is no way to
find a resolution and that's exactly the
Playbook that they used with the nurses
a few weeks ago and they're now doing
the same to the Junior so they should
learn their own lessons and get round
the table and find a resolution for
these things because I think patience
and clearly Hospital managers are very
worried about the level of service that
can be provided uh next week in in what
is usually quite a difficult week anyway
because of the holidays and so on
okay I I want to move on and ask you
about an advert that labor has tweeted
out claiming the Richie sunac doesn't
believe that adults who are convicted of
sexually assaulting children should be
jailed do you really believe that about
the prime minister
Look What We Are very clearly saying
today is that we have found these these
new figures uh through looking at the
government's own figures about the
levels of uh serious uh offenses that
have not resulted in custodial sentences
so yes that's for uh child uh offenses
relating to child abuse that we found
that over recent years over 4 000 adults
have escaped uh custodial sentences when
they've been found guilty of child abuse
we've also found that over 16
000 people who've been convicted of a
producing or sharing child pornography
material has have also escaped a
custodial sentences and that's because
there are real deep rooted problems in
our criminal justice system at the
moment for which the Prime Minister
obviously as the prime minister of the
country is responsible okay
we want something to do sorry to
interrupt about that okay but look at
those figures you're saying under the
Tories 4 500 adults convicted of
sexually assaulting children serve no
prison time Rishi sunak wasn't even
prime minister until 2010 these till
2015 these figures are from 2010 and
you're personalizing it I mean are you
really right in saying that the prime
minister
doesn't think these people should go to
prison
well as as you say these are figures
that not just from 2010 they're over
this whole uh period of 13 years but
he's only been prime minister for the
last year hasn't he but he is the prime
minister he is the current prime
minister he is the prime minister of the
conservative party or the conservative
government and we are highlighting their
record when it comes to uh sentencing
and what is happening in our criminal
justice system and I think it's really
important we're using these figures
today to highlight these structural and
very profound problems in the criminal
justice system which is uh threefold
essentially we've got this massive uh
backlog in the courts um which predates
that the pandemic because the
conservative government chose to close
down over 200 of our courts we've got
very very high reoffending rates because
the conservative government chose to
privatize the probation service hang on
a moment and we've also because the
result of all of that we've got
overflowing and full prisons so what is
happening is judges and those in the
criminal justice system don't feel able
to give out custodial sentences because
the system can't support those and I
think these are very very serious
questions that the Prime Minister
himself should be answering for okay so
so you stand by this statement
personally that Rishi sunak doesn't
think that adults convicted of sexually
assaulting children should go to prison
do you personally back that statement
well look it's a it's a digital graphic
highlighting a particular story which
I'm on here uh talking about today it's
a skit isn't it
you're very happy with what it says
you're comfortable with pointing the
finger at Richie soon act like this and
I'm comfortable with you know taking a
sort of standardized graphic that the
Prime Minister used himself many has
used himself many many times in recent
months uh and years to highlight
policies to highlight how one of his own
policies isn't isn't working and one of
his own uh things that he's responsible
for the criminal justice
isn't isn't working and so it's it's
taken from from that it's like a it's
what you do in in sort of political uh
campaigning it won't be to everybody's
uh taste but what's the important issue
here is What Lies Beneath that which I
think would be of of real importance to
to your viewers which is we do have
serious criminals now okay which is a
point almost almost routinely uh getting
uh more lenient custodial sentences and
they would otherwise do because the
system is creaking at the knees isn't
What Lies Beneath this the sentencing
guidelines isn't that what this is about
they'd be the same under labor wouldn't
they it's it's not actually about the
sentencing guidelines it's about the
capacity in the system to actually uh
Implement those those guidelines so when
you've got a huge backlog I think 62 000
cases currently snarled up in our in our
uh courts uh system uh because because
then the system wants to sort of deal
with that backlog it's sort of getting
things through this system faster and in
some cases more leniently when you've
got judges faced with wanting to give
custodial sentences but knowing that the
prisons are completely full they are
they are making judgments on that basis
around the prison capacity and whether
they can actually enforce those uh
custodial sentences so if the system as
a whole it's not it's not a particular
issue around sentencing guidelines that
is is meaning that these figures we
produce today and many other figures are
much more evidence that there is out
there at the moment that what we're
finding are are that that people are
seemingly getting off lightly for what I
think most people watching this program
would regard as very serious offenses
so just finally very briefly absolutely
no regrets no worries about this poster
at all you're totally comfortable with
it going out
well look I'm it's political campaigning
I'm I'm comfortable to be on your
program this morning defending what
we're talking about which is some really
serious issues around uh criminal the
criminal justice system and and how
would this country is just not dealing
with that